so I think our reason for really giving
a public face to the class in the course
itself but also on OpenCourseWare I
think there's a number of different
dimensions associated with that first I
think it's a sort of personal I think
that Professor teller started this class
and we really want to make these
materials available to people and really
kind of build on that legacy of the work
that he's done and if the work that
we've contributed this year can help the
class continue on and continue to grow
and flourish I think that's a really
exciting part the second piece i think
is really for the for the students the
opportunity to interact with people in
the wider community to share their work
the work that they've done I think all
of our students are very proud of the
work that they've done they really got
into the projects and working with their
clients and so in having a public
showcase at the end and having them
communicate their work online in video
or through ocw i think is part of the
learning experience i think and the
third piece is that we really think
there's a big opportunity in terms of
assistive technology education or kind
of project based education that we work
with people with disabilities in the
cambridge or boston area but in a lot of
ways this model could be applied to a
lot of other places a lot of other
colleges or universities in other in
other towns or cities in the United
States or around the world there's
there's really a huge need or a huge
opportunity I think to work in assistive
technology a lot of potential partners
just spread geographically and we want
to kind of communicate how we did it
here and maybe share some materials that
make it a little bit easier for somebody
thinking about doing this or maybe just
to inspire them to think about how they
might be able to work on a
a course or project like this I think
one of the more public aspects of the
class as well was the fact that we asked
our students to write a blog post over
the semester and so all of them had to
write four different blog posts and a
public blog for the class and and one
thing that's very important to me when
we teach about disability is that we're
not coming in as saviors and we're not
coming into like oh let's share
wonderful engineering knowledge with you
and one of the central aspects of this
class is that is user centered design
and we have to recognize that the
clients themselves understand a
disability the best and they understand
type of challenges that come with living
with a disability the best so one of the
great things about having those blog
posts was that the community outside
could also engage with students and say
well this is a good idea maybe this is
not a good idea have you considered this
other aspect and so we think that by
engaging our users that also just makes
the design process a lot more rigorous